ces trois dernières années les prix des
légumes frais ont augmenté de plus de
30% en France selon l'Insee alors les
consommateurs tentent de s'adapter
certains ont trouvé la solution venir
cueillir soi-même ses fruits et légumes
chez le producteur c'est ce que propose
depuis 28 ans l'exploitation les jardins
de Mellet à Parçay-Meslay un moyen de
profiter du soleil d'avoir des produits
frais locaux et de les payer moins cher
en économisant la main d'oeuvre
reportage de Léa Turquie
les sacs sont plein symboles d'une
cueillette réussie mur tomates ou
haricots le choix est large moyennant un
peu d'huile de coude c'est pas bon pour
l'odor mais ça va une manière de
profiter du beau temps tout en ramassant
quelques victuailles c'était l'occasion
de sortir mes petits-enfants
se balader ramasser des produits frais
et voilà parce que moi je suis sûr
qu'ils sont frais
du producteur au consommateur voilà ah
oui j'ai toujours des bons produits ici
donc jamais été déçu depuis de
nombreuses années donc je continue puis
c'est vraiment sympa les enfants de
pouvoir aller cueillir les fraises je
pense qu'elle en a mangé quelques unes
au passage elle en a plein les babines
mais voilà c'est très sympa il fait beau
en plus ou c'est d'où ils viennent et
puis c'est un côté un peu ludique avec
les enfants ramassa avec plaisir au
jardin de mêlée depuis 28 ans ce sont
les clients qui récoltent eux-mêmes
leurs produits au-delà d'une sortie en
famille c'est aussi une bonne occasion
de faire des économies à titre d'exemple
en France l'Insee indique un prix moyen
du kilo de courgettes à 2 euros 47 en
juin 2023 ici le kilo est à 1,95 une
différence de plus de 50 centimes de
quoi attirer les consommateurs on répond
à cette problématique de pouvoir d'achat
généralement on arrive à proposer des
produits moins chers que les
supermarchés puisque on s'économise la
main d'oeuvre et donc on peut proposer
des produits de qualité à des prix très
concurrents on surf sur l'air du temps
et les gens sont très contents de
pouvoir venir de nombreuses
exploitations agricoles proposent des
cueillettes au jardin de mêlée la
récolter possible sur une quinzaine
d'hectares avec plus d'une trentaine de
fruits et légumes disponibles